by the way i'm not an ancap
so don't even don't don't hit your wagon
to me on that one
end cap is an arcade captain capitalist
yes
not a not an end cap they have nice book
book shops
yeah they do i mean i'm not i'm not
gonna you know sit here and and
[ __ ] talk handcaps uh although i also
used to get into the conversations with
uh
with uh an ancom uh anarcho communist
uh a good friend of mine and he would he
would bring up this stuff and i'm like
yeah cool man i'm down with anarchy you
ain't gonna like it
what do you mean i go because i'm gonna
take on i'm gonna gather all kinds of
people dude i'm gonna make this i'm
gonna get the strongest together and
they're
going to take your [ __ ] okay okay on
that
topic i have um a friend of mine now
uh a fellow russian uh ukrainian
uh michael malus oh yeah i'm familiar
with michael meadows
i watched a little bit of your guys's uh
conversation
so this is really good to ask you
because uh
i like how he's in the white suit and
and you're in
the white and black but he he lives in
new york city
he is espouses ideas of anarchism
and his idea and this is different than
um
sort of the iron rand set of ideas
that there's a line between sort of
capitalism that's backed by the state
and just pure anarchism
and his idea that violence won't
take over in an anarchism
is one that feels to me
not grounded in reality i may be i may
be wrong so is there some
so uh the idea with pure capitalism is
that
you mean laissez faire completely
deregulated yeah
yeah well well what it will agree it'll
end up in one it'll end up in
if if you're anti-globalist it's going
to be that
it's going to be globalist 100 because
it has no con pure capitalism has no
consideration
for uh has no consideration for your
your native users
or of any sort like it doesn't doesn't
matter and but the idea of governments
is that the land
little piece of land geographically
you're born on
means you're going to stick to whatever
founding documents
created that little land so anarchism is
against that
and the argument is you should be able
to choose which ideas you live with
and the concern there is nobody uh
this geographical land the governments
that organize on that land will not
do not need to protect you from the
violence and my sense is there does need
to be an army there does need to be
police
that help however the form that police
takes
but there needs to be a more centralized
not completely centralized but more
centralized
safety net of to protect you from the
violence scale again
right so if you want to have your
anarchist
utopia well we'll call you your
anarchist
creation here at certain scale i'm sure
it's
doable you know um but
as it scales as the scale increases it's
completely untenable
and a state will emerge a state will
always emerge
because even people always think of
states as as like people rubbing their
hands and smoking cigars and back rooms
and just out of nowhere coming around
it's like oh we're going to create this
big centralized thing and just so we can
tell everybody what to do and we can be
in charge
i mean i know that there are people like
that that exist
that they would like to do things of
that nature and that they see
the use of power as
something to be used more for their
their personal gains
over first which again self-interest in
human beings
but uh but eventually a state people
want us they want something to go like
okay
who's taking care of this and who's
taking care of that and who and how do
we create
some sort of uh some sort of uh
protocol for this like okay well when
it's not bob when is it susie when is it
whatever i mean like how do we
you know it's got to get done if we want
this thing to become bigger if we want
our
all of our plumbing to work right if we
want it's just i'm sorry a state's going
to happen a state is also
when you think about it it's supposed to
have consideration to tribe
right so if people think that we're not
tribes well
you're not you're not really thinking
very deeply we're all tribes of a sort
and uh everybody likes to use the word
tribalism in this idea
of of this uh antagonistic concept but
and while sure tribalism can be
antagonistic tribalism can also be
a positive thing or i could just say it
just seems to be a natural thing people
you know they create their their groups
of one sort or another
and so when you have
well when you think about where when
nation states really started to become a
thing
uh and i don't mean even the more modern
looking variants that we could think
back of and say the 19th century or
something like that
right even older than that i mean do you
think the assyrians didn't have a state
of some sort of course they did
um they how do you increase your your
your your empire if you don't actually
have a place to start from
a ruler so you're saying like naturally
when you start talking thinking about
scale of humans
naturally states emerge
and so can we try to make an argument
for anarchism which is uh
okay okay
so uh anarchy in a sense is in
opposition
to the unhelpful unproductive
inefficient bureaucracies that
eventually
the states lead to yes and that's what
we can see i mean
i would say less anarchy let more
study james burnham you know
uh or well
any anybody that wants to talk about the
the managerial problem and the matter
so you you have a sense i hope
maybe let's think like what is the path
forward with the
inefficient state is it revolution or
is it to work within the system to
constantly improve it
man i don't know that one i mean my
general sense
uh and maybe this is the nietzschean
part of me is that
yeah it'll it would take maybe not even
just
maybe not even defining uh it
specifically as a revolution maybe it
would just take
just total calamity to to get people to
stop being
shitty to not stop being a lesser
version of themselves to stop
thinking more about uh things from
you know the paradigm that we existed
now where we're giving so much value to
stuff that isn't really all that
valuable
you know where we're so concerned about
likes
and i don't just mean like whether we
get them or not but that
oh man maybe we should take this off of
our platform because this is too
destabilizing to people and it's like
because once you exceed dunbar's number
i think it's actually without having
the right faculties which
would need to be developed because this
is dealing with
this is dealing with tech that brings
things
ways of approaching being that we are
not
naturally programmed to be able
uh to handle appropriately so and i
think it's
even even even more it's even more
detrimental to women than men
because i think women have a more
natural proclivity towards
group association and
and more group oriented thinking and
patterning
and now and with also coupled with
seemingly more sensitivity towards
towards human uh states
so i feel like women like the classic
idea is like oh you know women are
psychic you know i have a sick sense and
what have you and i think that's just a
uh a way of
uh simplifying what i think is that
women may be more in tune with
picking up on the unsaid like they might
be better at
seeing um physical cues
uh inflection and tone like different
like they may be
far more sensitive to these things which
to me would make sense because dealing
with
children that can't uh communicate
er so so generally more understanding
and all the fulfillment right now okay
now whether it be a woman or a man but
especially
with even the social uh push on this
concept of
empathy which of course it gets to the
point where it loses any meaning anymore
like people use the word empathy
absolutely incorrectly all the time and
they don't even understand
what you're really asking of people but
let's just take it as
as we're using empathy in the correct
sense and you're taking on
the emotional content of the thing
itself
now you open that up to thousands of
people maybe hundreds of thousands of
people
all across the world that you will never
meet that you will never know that
you're not even getting an
actual true representation most of the
time of who these people
are you're you're meeting persona and
some of these personas
are even deliberately created
to elicit a response inauthentically
are you referring to bots or uh could be
bots or actual people
bots are one thing but i mean there are
literal people out there that will
create something create uh gofundmes for
for
tragedies that never didn't really or
events that didn't happen or
any number of things okay i mean burn
their own house down and then say you
know we were attacked
and then it comes down you did it to
yourself because you wanted money and
empathy and this that and
you wanted all this this emotional
wealth let's say this emotional
uh coin as well as actual if possible
you wanted to leverage it in some way
that's not the majority of people but i
would say
a good amount of folks are thinking well
if i post this photo
and i put this little blurb in there i
bet i can get this much cachet out of it
in this sense
and i'm not even and this isn't just a
reference to like butt pics and stuff
like that
because clearly obviously people
understand that that
uh our inborn sexual nature
is easy to manipulate i mean that's
pretty
pretty obvious but you're you're saying
this kind of new medium of communication
on social media is uh
is is unnatural and it preys on us and
so as you
you want this you know you look at
you look at an anarchist kind of mindset
right and so you just like
there's no there there is no overarching
state
to to create any kind of
uh structure right and so if you have
that unfettered capitalism aspect with
it
and before i say anything particularly
damning about unfettered capitalism uh
i'm a massive capitalist because i view
capitalism
essentially as what it boils down to i
get these arguments to people too they
start giving me all these extra
definitions about capitalism like no no
this is obviously some sort of theory
you're taking from other [ __ ] but that
doesn't describe capitalism capitalism
is
the ability for us to create
whatever we want you know create our
thoughts ideas
physical things and trade them freely
amongst each other uh
in ways that we find um
acceptable right you know i'm not even
using the word fair
because i might think it's fair to me
you might think
huh well i mean that was actually i
think he what he thought was unfair to
him and it's more fair to me
and then someone a third observer goes
oh man you shoulda you should not have
paid that for that you should have paid
this and it's like well you know what it
works for me
without sufficiently acceptable that you
you both agree to the transaction
correct
and uh you know but but also at the
at the root of that is freedom right and
as far as i can tell
i've been banging this around in my head
it's like
for every one unit of freedom you need
two units of
accountability and if you don't have
that
what you end up with is
human self-interest we're not even going
to get into evil human self-interest
sabotaging other things even not in a
sense to be malicious
okay so in terms of uh let's put this as
mathematically speaking i love this
so anarchism is more like two units of
freedom and
one unit of accountability or maybe zero
units of accountability possibly i mean
the anarchists tend to think like no
everyone will be accountable
[ __ ] they will when have you seen this
happen in real life
you know i mean people aren't even
accountable in their revolutions after
that time so
uh you aren't looking at
the way people really are it's like marx
is like
yeah the people are like this they're
like that look at how capitalism does it
i mean
he of course assigns a lot of really
ridiculous economic principles in
practice
uh but and also assumes that everybody
you know who
makes any profit from anything is
somehow stealing it and you know
really assigns a negative moral aspect
to him and then it's like oh yeah but
then eventually communism will happen no
one will act that way anymore and you're
like whoa hold on you just said that
people are all
are you saying it's all due to
capitalism or it's
is it innate it's just it's a
fundamental
misunderstanding of and it's like hey
look at you you're like a notorious like
anti-semitic angry like
uh just absolute curmudgeon of a human
being who seems to be
really not all that fun to be around
marx yeah and then it's just like so you
have to think like if if there was
one billion marxists in the world how
would they behave
it would be absolutely they would hate
each other
so bad and you know this isn't for me to
even poison the well on marx is like oh
his personality sucks
like there's lots of people whose
personality sucks that doesn't mean they
can't make
i don't know that it's never what you
know what somebody argues
he's just a he's a loner i mean i don't
know this personality sucked at all
let me walk that back and that he was
human saying his personality sucked
he was sometimes contradictory
irrational
sometimes he was uh quite
sexist despite the emails i've gotten
that uh that that's
that told me that uh that there's
there's people has written to me that uh
nietzsche has been unfairly labeled as
sexist
in his discussion about women i'm
pretty sure there's a bunch of documents
where he's just like
he's just a bitter guy i i will agree
with you and marx is as bitter as they
come to
but um you know what bitterness
in and of itself doesn't make like
wha why i hate marxism comes from you
know
the the whole the entirety of the thing
and but the dismissal of humanity but
i'm not going to
say that marxism or practice man
you can find any forbidden book and it
could have something good in it it's
colonel's a good idea
yeah and like at the end of the day you
know marx is a human being
he's got a nice beard he does he had a
hell of a beard yeah
a decent portrait i mean he looks like
the kind of guy like i wouldn't want to
meet him in a dark alley
but thankfully i don't think he was much
of a fighter
but in any case i mean
you